dress for success southern nevada has
teamed up with max pond luxury to offer
women and our community programs to help
those in need of getting back on their
feet and into the workforce so joining
us today is norma in triago from dress
for success southern nevada and michael
matt from max pond luxury we're so happy
to have you guys here
so happy to be here well i have to put
it out there that i did just join the
board for dress for success southern
nevada and i'm so honored to be part of
this organization so let's start with
that let's give a little background on
what dress for success does in our
community absolutely dress for success
southern nevada helps women navigate the
world of work our sole focus and mission
is to help women achieve economic
empowerment and we do that by providing
them with a network of support the
professional attire that they need as
well as the development tools so that
they can be successful in working in
life well and you have these new
partnerships in the community that are
really special and go a really long way
so mike i'll bring you into the
conversation here why was it important
to team up with dress for success and
tell us about this program you have
going on well we've been a partner for
several years with uh their sale annual
sale and it just makes nothing but sense
you know we're in the luxury business
we do handbags belts sunglasses all the
luxury goods and we have people that
need them and this is just a great
partnership and as we move on we're
moving on to an internship program that
we're very exciting about so tell us a
little bit about how that works and what
the women will be learning in that
internship and just kind of what it
looks like i'm going to pass that to you
because you'll probably be able to yeah
i think what we want to emphasize and
what i'm so grateful to have business
leaders like michael who partner with
organizations such as our is that we've
gone through such challenging times and
right now you know we are in jeopardy of
going backwards with uh three decades of
progress for women in the workforce
right and so programs like this what i
call return to ship work programs and
paid internships like what michael is
offering really gives a career
progression and a pathway for women and
it's about skill building and i think
that's what i love um that he's creating
also for young talent we help women who
are 16 and up so they're young women who
can start paving a career pathway and
learning about i mean there's the
opportunity right to learn about
merchandising they have a proprietary
unique uh cell system right that you can
teach them also to assess the value i
mean this whole thing with the lone
world that is quite different and so
what we want them you cannot be what you
you cannot see and i think that that's
what's amazing in michael creating this
pathway and investment well and these
programs wouldn't be possible without
the support of the community and coming
up we have a big success showcase that
brings in everyone especially women in
the community to support our fellow
women let's talk about that really
quickly it's coming up this friday yes
we're so excited so we're having our
success showcase and champagne lunch
this may 6th at the fourth season
um you can get tickets now before
their noon left and um really it's a
celebration with our partners with our
business leaders with our community
partners with our clients and our
volunteers really to celebrate the
resiliency of women right it's been so
challenging and so we are going to share
some of that career trajectory and
pathway of women who are now successful
came through the doors of dress for
success and are now paying it forward
and so we're really honored to toast and
have this amazing fun event we're going
to have a dj we're going to have an
after party so you can't miss it so just
if you go to dress dressforsuccess
southernnevada.org
you can find all the information on the
event and get your tickets great well
come hang out with us on friday it's
going to be a great time but also going
back to an amazing cause michael norma
thank you so much for being here i'm
honored to be part of this organization
we'll see you all on friday and for now